in light of recent events what is the
best course of action when confronted by
an obvious abuse of authority resulting
in personal injury due to an innocent
person to an innocent person oh to an
init say to an innocent person that that
occurs in one's presence at what point
is it acceptable to physically engage
with the assailant even though the
assailant has some kind of authority
sorry that's two questions wait
whatwhat's the recent event the recent
event is the person on the airplane
getting dragged off and injured
yeah because that was over like all that
yeah yeah overbooked flight yeah so what
and you know obviously I guess you could
put more recent events is you know if
you if you could have a police officer
that's doing something you could have a
bouncer you know I'm sure you have
plenty of stories about your nightclub
days besides just wearing jeans in the
wrong area unless you know has a big
violation but so so here's what here's
here's my answer that's what do you do
and one of those things has happened
first of all the people that are in the
situation are wrapped up in the
situation they're emotionally mentally
wrapped up in the situation the
situation has escalated they're caught
in a storm mmm and you're not in the
storm you're outside the storm so what
do most people do and they see that
storm going on what do most people do
tell me panic no they pull out their
iPhones and they start recording the
situation that's what they do that's
what everyone does Hey oh there's a
fight going on worldstar let's rev it up
you don't I'm saying yeah well they have
a lot of good fights on there but you
have to watch so yeah well cause you
learn from you see we way people act you
see some human nature in videos so
that's what people do so what you
actually want to do instead of pulling
out your video is you want to try and
get them out of that moment emotionally
you want to talk to them like a normal
person engage with them you know hey hey
sir you need to calm down that's just a
police officer he doesn't mean any harm
hey hey you know officer that that guy's
not a threat to you right now
you know just take a step back it looks
like
he's trying to relax you know you want
to talk them disengage them getting
their heads out of those bad scenarios
yeah and you know being a calm voice say
some things like I said say something
hey officer there's a lot of people that
are videoing this right now you know
just a lot of people saw what happened
so let's it's it's you you don't have to
do anything else you can let's let's get
this person under control I can give you
a hand or whatever you know you just
wanna you and and of course what is it
what is their initial reaction to be
back at you just back away or if you
don't shut up you're you know you don't
know and and so you need to absorb that
right say hey look I'm not I'm not
giving you any threats at all I'm just
here to help out I don't want to see any
trouble don't want you to get in trouble
you just want to talk to people and get
them to they get them out of that
emotional storm that they're in both
sides both sides because it's a really
nasty situation you know when you don't
listen to me when I start to hurt you
when I grab your your wrist let's say
like one of those like police pain
compliance type moves I grab your wrist
and I start to twist it you as a human
being the natural instinct some people
might have the instinct to comply but a
lot of people have the instinct if you
grab me and start hurting me I'm gonna
go away yes okay you're resisting now
you're resisting to what I need you i
need to go Harker
well the harder I go the more you resist
and you see where this is going
next thing you know I'm beating you in
the head because I don't know how to use
a show called unfortunately because in
some areas the choke codes are illegal
hmm so again as the outsider you want to
pull them out of that you want to talk
to them you want to get them to see that
outside of this emotional storm that
they're in both sides both sides are an
emotional storm physical intervention
you know now we are talking like this is
a serious step you start stepping into
these scenarios you don't know you want
to be very very careful about stepping
in a tease one of these situations and
even that physical escalation should be
our physical intervention should be just
with the sole purpose of
de-escalating right you're not walking
over and you know grabbing a guy no hey
you know it's like a hand on the
shoulder hey sir a officer hey you know
tsa agent or whoever you are
hey let's just calm down let you want me
to give you a hand getting this person
under control you know you you don't
want to get these people to where now
you become because as soon as you do
that you just ended up a storm
yeah you part of the storm now yeah even
though you're trying not to be you're
you're you're entering the storm so you
gotta be very very cautious about what
you're doing there and you know what
would I do in a situation where I saw
someone getting you know beat to death
you know I'm gonna do what I just said
you know now might I go a little bit
further because I have a lot of
experience and maybe I can handle the
situation and deescalate it physically
yeah and you know you see this sometimes
where something we escalating in
innocent civilians will come and help an
officer secure a person so those there's
ways to do it yeah you just got to be
very very cautious when you do those
when you do that because the the other
piece of this is and again you see this
on on YouTube you don't know what
happened to get to this point you don't
know who that person is who the
perpetrator is right the perpetrator
might look totally innocent but you
don't know any background so when you
start stepping in there you might be
stepping in there to defend a person
that just shot a person or a person that
just you know got caught doing something
or a person that really did resist the
cops hard and do do some damage so I
don't I don't know and I'm generally
gonna side with with a police officer
right I mean the police officer I'm I'm
respecting that they that they're doing
the right thing yeah and sort of step in
there and start making something happen
isn't is not gonna generally work out in
a good way
maybe you can help them get the
perpetrator under control but yeah to
make the assumption that because a cop
has escalated to a point of violence
that the cop is and how to control crazy
cop it's but not an accurate assumption
the most likely that's the wrong
assumption you know you know cops are
not walking around waiting to to beat
the crap out of people that's not what
they're doing they don't want to do
yeah when it happens it hits something
something has generally led up to when
we see it in a case that isn't like that
that's why we see it as it's now news
it's now news yeah
so be very very careful about that again
you know most of the time you know just
try and deescalate it verbally ask if
they need any assistance ask if you can
call 911 and get more assistance for
them ask if they need any help talk to
that you know do that take that approach
if you have to physically intervene
especially if you have some experience
you know let them know what you're doing
do you need any help do you need any
assistance that type of thing and I'm
sure we'll get some feedback from from
some cops on this one and it'll be good
yeah yeah I feel it when I was back to
the bouncer situation when guys would
you know fight would break out so in a
club on a fight break breaks out is more
chaotic than you know in the street when
you see two guys fighting so it's a
little bit more dangerous when you jump
into the fight to try to break it up
because if you just jump in and grab the
guy the guy doesn't know if you're
trying to break up the fight or if
you're a guy you're just another
attacker yeah exactly right so he's
gonna start swinging or whatever and
that's not to mention any of that guy's
friends who sees you do that in the dark
you know all this you know the dark
night club lights whatever so well he
might hate you whatever and then you
know bottles came in it can be dangerous
so if you jump in there with before you
even touch the person you you're already
saying break it what I would always say
is either break it up or or calm down
like calm down guys break it up break it
up before you even touch them and they
hear that so when they feel you they
don't feel a punch it's like calm down
calm down they feel you kind of it's
more of a light giving a compared to the
the guy who he's fighting with it's not
a punch it's not a wrestling moves
nothing it's like you're breaking it up
and you just gave me a good reminder to
if you're on the outside and you see
something like this going on like if
you're on that plane you see this this
this passenger getting roughed up you
know hey hey hey passenger just calm
down do what they're telling you to do
just do what their just comply with what
they're doing to do you know just relax
let them cuff you just relax you know
you can take you know
definitely heard cops say this actually
I heard the guy that was on Sam Harris's
podcast like if you want to got an issue
with what a cops doing to you bring it
to the court we'll let your lawyers
handle it you don't handle it right
there because you're gonna lose you're
gonna lose that situation you're gonna
end up hurt you're gonna end up injured
is gonna be a bad scenario so the same
thing tell them to tell you know if you
see someone getting getting roughed up
then hey hey man we're all watching just
comply just do what they're telling you
to do and take it up to with a lawyer
later just try and get that person to
calm down cuz that's you know chances
are you know the police officer he's
arrested thousands of people put his
hands on thousands of people that person
that's getting roughed up
they haven't they've not been arrested
you know I can guarantee you that United
passenger probably never been arrested
in his life so here he is and like I
said you start to pull me I'm gonna
resist yeah I don't people don't pull me
no but don't pull me but now all the
sudden we got an incident going on so if
someone saying hey listen just listen to
what they're telling you you need to
just calm down you don't want this to
get any worse that type of thing yeah
talk to people and get them to detach a
little bit